hey I was gonna press my name it wait
you best get anointed that I do that I
mean my name is Peter Pan like every
[ __ ] video oh my god oh my god oh my
god Oh
so for it a few days or weeks ago I
announced the Photoshop competition
where I basically took a bunch of
pictures of myself and said here you go
do whatever you want with it and I'll
I'll review it for a video so that's
what we're gonna do here today I've seen
some of them and they're [ __ ]
ridiculous here's a quick rundown of the
pictures I sent in beautiful stuff yes
whoa solicit whoa whoa just scroll
through and oh my god already am I an
alias what the [ __ ] is this ah
nice bro man look at that camel toe [ __ ]
yes
gangsta pose with that sick chain it
looks so real am i marrying Edgar
instead of my chair is that what's
coming this is my rainbow dreams well
this is a classic so I'm Edgar and
Edgar's me if I look so happy about it
this is page one Adam two hundred great
oh my I want to lick those fingers if
you know what I mean oh god [ __ ] that Oh
some of these are just [ __ ] creepiest
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] what is this oh
my god I know Edgar Edgar sir
haha s boy that's awesome
well that's kind of disturbing that is
some fabulous [ __ ] [ __ ]
if this isn't fabulous I don't know what
fable this is beep I the duck [ __ ] yeah
Oh oh yeah
my first injury I hope you like it yep I
love it that's [ __ ] awesome [ __ ]
sake gross hahahaha oh my god that's
pretty cool
[ __ ] hell man nice sweet and I'll all
you bros are equally weird as me this is
[ __ ] amazing to see like what the
[ __ ] man oh well that's not disturbing
it out thanks Alicia ooh la la
SFI Oh who's that pokémon
it's Pikachu ha ha ha let's just say
someone got shrekt oh my god
oh my god that's [ __ ] disgusting ha
ha ha that's creative I like that
just me and Eminem on the stage they're
big damn that actually looks pretty
legit now that's a quality album culvert
right there oh well that's nice this is
how I would look like when I grow up
attack on kids
no not Edgar I'm so cute oh hello Peter
Elsa Oh for [ __ ] sake I went with
destructive parents oh oh man you rose
hello they they attack them kids edits
nice nipples well I think we have a
winner
right there yeah Big Pimpin now that's
how you model right there adventure bros
whoa that hair is majestic what the [ __ ]
am i doing to Edgar could well I'm gonna
have nightmares now thank you very much
miss what the [ __ ] is this
you [ __ ] weirdos oh yeah Leviosa
boots spot dunks tonight we dine with
ducks this is an accurate representation
of when we invade Norway seems like an
awesome movie accurate representation of
me inside horror games the [ __ ] is what
the what the [ __ ] is but that's what I
of course sir pretty pie the Dorito
the last of Broce nice we look so
excited oh my god this one's awesome the
great masturbator
Thanks thank you so much spend time with
senpai fuckstick
it seems like an awesome like t tween
fanfic book or some [ __ ] oh dude that
was [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] but uh like
these corner these corpses will never be
as fabulous as me hahahahaha oh man [ __ ]
yeah I don't know what's happening here
and I'm not gonna ask yellow is evil so
don't drink your piss
inspirational nuclear brofist nice oh my
god that is the sexiest creature this
universe has ever seen oh my god that's
actually an awesome vector
thank you much thank you for shelf now
you'll never even receive that plaque
[ __ ] hell it's [ __ ] but if when I
do I'm gonna dam recreate that picture
oh my god let's [ __ ] it awesome
oh ha ha ha ha ha ha alright what the
actual [ __ ] I've never been this turned
on in my life oh yeah I saw this one
this one is so cool hello though well
it's awesome Oh what - it is - I'd be
fabulous if you don't agree you're
Hatters whoa whoa dude this was so cool
ah this is cool to the bro galaxy
hahahaha
I look good
yeah that's what I'm talking about one
direction now with more pits that's how
it should be what the actual [ __ ] am I
looking at oh man what the actual that
yeah beautiful yes so inspirational yeah
too fat for you
holy [ __ ] I look beautiful as [ __ ] so
fabulous turned out prettier than I
expected [ __ ] please you know I'd be
fabulous
oh Jesus that's awesome subscribe to
purifies tunnel captain Sweden [ __ ] yeah
oh man
alright press ah this is so much fun
really cool to see so many submissions
I've gone through a little less than
half of them so I think we'll have to
end this episode here thank you for so
much for all every single submission I
had like I said it's so much fun to go
through these I really did not expect
you brothers to be so awesome at making
these and it's just really cool to see
so thank you both so much
and I'll see in the next one as always
stay awesome brush let's fix his nose
it's more of a [ __ ] potato I guess
hahahaha